[Music]
across the country many young people are
taking
jobs to help their families make ends
meet
since the pandemic started an estimated
3 million students
have not attended virtual or in-person
classes
for some that's because they're now
working mega oliver is outside a high
school in newark new jersey with more on
teenagers
balancing school and work meg good
morning
anthony good morning we spoke with two
students one from here at arts high
school in newark new jersey
and the other in los angeles both told
us when the pandemic hit
they felt the pressure to step in and
help their families one expert told us
their stories
are not unusual several days a week
melody videl gets a ride to the mills at
jersey gardens mall where she works at
the bakery chain
cinnabon in the fall the high school
senior took the job to help her mom
financially what was your biggest fear
my biggest fear was being homeless
but trying to balance remote learning
and work is taking a toll on the 18 year
old
how overwhelming is this it's so
overwhelming overwhelmingly stressful i
find it hard to
to live sometimes you find it hard to
live sometimes yes
because of the stress maria medina is
melody's mother
she's a party entertainer and does face
and body painting
how hard has this last year been
financially for you
i watched a career that i have been
working
on for 12 years go completely dead
would you be able to make ends meet
without her helping
yes and no i mean i would i can figure
i can manage things i've been doing it
for years but her health
has been a blessing in the u.s around
17.5
million young people between 16 and 24
are employed
and many to help their families get by
seventeen-year-old joanna lopez is one
of them
why did you need this job well i wanted
to help my mom because she's
a struggling single mom the high school
senior from los angeles
juggles an exhausting load all remote
school during the day
and several days a week she works at a
fast food restaurant until midnight
her mother was laid off because of kovid
and that's when i was there i was like
okay
now it's time to actually step it up
because i'm a little brother
lopez brings in about eight hundred
dollars a month and gives 500 to her mom
for rent in other bills you're doing a
great thing for your mom
are you worried about your mom
not really i know that she's a strong
woman this has got to be overwhelming
for you
you're only 17 years old i try to keep a
positive attitude why did you want to
share your story i want other people to
see that they're not the only ones that
struggle
are you seeing more high school students
trying to bring home paycheck
absolutely young people are under
incredible pressure to contribute to the
finances in the home
elmer roald dahn is the executive
director of communities and schools of
los
angeles his organization works with
lopez and
hundreds of other students and their
families to help provide
social emotional academic and even
financial support to keep
kids in school what do you think will
happen now that some of these high
schools will start to reopen after
spring break
and you have students trying to juggle
school and jobs
well i think that it's going to put both
the schools
and the students in a very difficult
place and i think it's going to
force students to have to pick between
their education
and bringing home that income well don
says his organization tries to encourage
young people
to focus on a long-term vision for
themselves
like higher education certainly the
income that they're bringing in
right now is a huge lifeline for their
families and
you know and all jobs are respectable
but we also know that
the potential is there for them to do a
lot more
for melody just the thought of doing
more is keeping her afloat
she hopes to go to college next year you
have something to look forward to
yeah i do you're helping your family get
by
pay the rent make sure that the
electrical gets paid how does that make
you feel
it makes you feel happy makes me feel
like maybe we're not
gonna be homeless it's so scary to think
about that
so much pressure but they both have so
much potential melody tells us she wants
to study
graphic design at a community college
next year and joanna the student out in
los angeles also plans to go to college
she wants to be a music therapist
tony meg thank you very much it's a
reminder that the child
tax credit can help struggling parents
like that so maybe their kids don't have
to choose between school
and and that job to support the family
well you feel for a melody and joanna
i'm
just going to say but in the meantime to
hear melody say
sometimes i don't want to live just gave
me chills you got to hang in there
because we all know it's true it does
get better but when you're
in it it must seem extremely
overwhelming and joanna's saying you
know
no she doesn't worry about her mother
his tears are streaming down her face
i never thought of that aspect of the
the layers of covet and the
damage that it causes and the teens feel
that the degree to which it
has reverberated you know also so far
and you're looking at
kids worrying about their parents yeah
and wearing as melody says worrying
about being homeless yeah these kids
have their antenna up they're picking up
what's going on in the house
no they absorb it all right meg thank
you very much powerful story